I taught I guess now it's more reaction
since tonight's monologue we have a
election in 22 days author of the
best-selling book the briefing former
White House press secretary
America's first action senior advisor
Sean Spicer and the author of a brand
new bestseller Spygate former Secret
Service agent and our a TV contributor
dan bond Geno you know Sean look I know
you went through a lot when you were
press secretary in words or one thing
but when you have leaders the former
candidate for the Democratic Party
saying we can't be civil with them you
have the former attorney general of the
u.s. ain't kick them you know if they go
look we kick them then you got Maxine
Waters says you see these these cabinet
people you get a crowd and you follow
them into department stores and gas
stations and and grocery stores well we
saw that too your successor Sarah
Sanders Pam Bondi secretary Neilson Ted
Cruz somebody's gonna get killed here
but they don't seem to care you're
absolutely right somebody did get shot
Steve Scalise the this deranged person
on the left went out and shot up a group
of House Republican members playing
baseball it has a very violent turn and
and I think the the concern to me is
that it all seems coming in one
direction and instead of denouncing it
which they you know the media would be
out there asking the right to do that if
it was going in that direction instead
you see their left doubling down Hillary
Clinton Maxine Waters as you mentioned
Eric Holder these people are doubling
down inciting it and if this was the
right doing it to the left Shawn if
these were Donald Trump supporters there
would be outrage on every one of those
left-wing cable shows that we see time
and again it's outrage when Donald Trump
go ahead yeah no I was just gonna say
it's amazing I've never seen such a
double standard they justify the actions
on on the left you saw the commentators
and hosts on CNN saying please don't
call it a mob which it clearly is they
would begin there we say it's a mop yeah
I mean all right that's amazing to learn
and
the New York Post's actually said these
are the people that are wanted there was
not only Portland last weekend and this
weekend but New York this weekend and a
bunch of anarchists go to the New York I
guess GOP club Republican Club whatever
it happens to be and they're writing you
know that they're committing vandalism
anarchists signs that they're putting up
etcetera and then there's a
confrontation on the streets there
that's not what the media says they
don't tell the whole story they get
wrong in the beginning kind of pissed
off that even for a second believed half
of what they wrote and this is coming
from the left the radical left but look
at Alec Baldwin the lowest ratings in
the history basically of any network
television it's never been that low or
Michael Moore's movie failing is this
gonna translate to the ballot box in 22
days well Sean were already seeing some
of the results of that I mean you
covered at the beginning of your show
Missouri North Dakota we're even seeing
a race closing in Michigan you know John
James and insurgent candidate James is a
rock star love him he's a stud I love
him he's great his videos a terrific
we're already seeing it happening Sean
but just two quick points on this number
one the left's religion is state power
that's their religion when they lose
state power they have nothing to fall
back on I'm not talking about a little
Democrats talking about the radical left
they are socialists their religion and a
genuflect at the altar state power when
they lose it they erupt this is what
happens to but you know you know how
they lied and they they disseminated the
false information dan yeah remember yeah
all the phony dossier was leaked before
the election then it was used to set up
the whole Muller investigation the
pieces are all coming together but
Maxine Waters even revealed they keep
saying to me don't say it don't say in
people will do it but don't say it now
the Center for American Progress John
Podesta group there now out there say
don't talk about immigration it's no
don't tell people what you really want
to do so for them to win they got a lie
and hide who they really are
it's a pretty revealing instance it and
then we have the tape of Mejia you know
librettist it but hey Sean I'll tell you
the interesting is you look at a
candidate like Kristen Cinema out in
Arizona that
called the people of Arizona crazy she
talked about the I mean she is she is
all of these tapes start unraveling
about her talking about it being okay to
join the Taliban she's calling her own
confided look what Adam of course is it
in the blind Sheikh case Lynn Stewart
but there's a double standard how they
cover the right and how they cover the
left and the reality is is that these
folks are trying to cover up the route
all they want to do is talk about the
style and substance of Donald Trump they
can't talk about the agenda and they
can't talk about the results because
it's whether its economic policy or
foreign policy the president's getting
things done and they know they can't
beat what he's getting done I think I
see things moving in the right direction
in the Senate Sean Spicer but the house
it's too hard to tell I've been
identifying Ted we can close their
Islands of power Sean yeah I think it's
getting close yeah but do you think I
mean you think it's closer but are you
confident that the house remains in
Republican hands no I'm not until people
get out there and realize what a big
difference Nancy Pelosi Maxine Waters
Adams ship the whole lot of them are
going to be versus they stopped the
Trump agenda dead in their tracks people
need to understand November this agenda
is on the ballot you need to get out and
vote you know I will say this if you
vote anybody that votes for Nancy Penn
for a Democrat you're voting for Nancy
if you vote in the Senate it's right or
a Democrat you're voting for Chuck
you're voting for their lies and hidden
agenda you're right there's a lot at
stake all right thank you